Scientist working with NASA's Kepler
telescope believe they may have discover
what may be the most earth like clone
at the date Kepler for 50 to be orbits.
It start at a very similar distance
at earth orbits. It's star. In fact,
it's here is only 20 days longer.
It is likely a rocky planet for ups.
A billion years old was in the eras,
60% larger in 1400 light years away in
the constellation sickness because this
world has been an orbit around its
star for around 6 billion years in the
habitable zone, scientists are hopeful
that life has evolved in flourished here.
In fact,
they're calling it the best chance so
far under just several earth like planets
discovered,
including capita 20 to be
scientist or not sure if the planner
host life and because it is 1400 layers
away, who not like they'd be a
certain for a decent amount of time.
Though they were saying that
plant's transported here
from Earth would likely be
able to survive and someone could receive
a healthy tan. How healthy you have.
A 10 though is yet to
be determined as again,
much of the planet is still unknown
as well as completely redefining or
understanding of biology and
a universe, Kepler, 42 B,
and they provide insight on the future
of earth due to its greater age and its
similarity to our planet Kepler for 50
to be maybe our best hope for Iti to date
that may indeed be among billions and
billions of life harboring planets in the
universe in the end. Only a time and
perseverance hotel. What do you think?
So could there be life on this world?
Would it be intelligent?
Let me know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe and check out
my channel for more videos on
Australian meat science in general,
and much more so I give her watching.